Keanu Reeves' no longer really retired
assassin has killed hundreds of opponents
when they screwed him over or got in his way.
There’s no stopping Baba Yaga. Here are some of
the hardest-to-watch, most memorably brutal
deaths in the "John Wick" series thus far.
This is the death that set John Wick off on
his killing spree, and any animal lover can
likely relate to such an urge. Underneath all the
glorious violence and destruction, this franchise
is ultimately an ode to man's best friends: dogs
and cars. Director Chad Stahelski professed a love
of dogs to Uproxx in 2019, saying his began as a
child in a household that raised Irish Wolfhounds.
Stahelski's background inspired him to incorporate
dogs into the "John Wick" films. We see this first
with the adorable baby beagle gifted to Wick
posthumously by his recently deceased wife,
Helen. Her passing sets the stage for the
first film, and knowing her time was near,
she scheduled Daisy's arrival for when
John would need her most. The puppy
acts as an anchor for the grieving husband,
giving him a reason to keep going each day.
Tragically, his tentative grip on becoming
whole slips away when Russian thugs break
into his house, kill Daisy, and steal his
prized '69 Mustang — a wedding gift from
Helen. It's heartbreaking to see the little
puppy die, so much so that even the actor
tasked with "killing" the puppy on-set felt
the need to cuddle Daisy between takes. You
can't blame John for hunting down every person
affiliated with killing that innocent puppy
and stealing his car. But, thankfully, in
real life the beagle is alive and well,
and has been living with a loving family
who have since renamed him "Wick."
Wick committed the ultimate unforgivable sin in
"John Wick Chapter 2," when he killed Santino
D'Antonio on the neutral ground of "The
Continental." This set every bounty hunter
in the city after Wick, who attempted to lose
them in "Chapter 3 – Parabellum" by hiding out
in a Central Park horse stable. In one
of his most creative and brutal moves,
Wick used one of the horses in the stables
as a weapon to fend off his pursuers.
Placing the horse between himself and one
of the assassins, Wick encouraged the horse
to back kick his opponent in the sternum. He
then slapped the horse's thigh so it followed
with a double-back kick to the guy's jaw, who
instantly drops like a sack of potatoes. Then,
Wick wrapped the horse's reins around his last
living opponent's neck, dragging him from the
stable behind him. It’s pretty intense, and
not a position anyone would ever want to be in.
After escaping from the stable on
his death horse in "Parabellum,"
Wick is pursued by motorcyclist gangsters
through downtown Manhattan. In the process,
Wick executes some amazing trick riding and
manages to vanquish all those in pursuit.
The motorcyclists get shot in the face
and crash into other cars pretty hard.
Amazingly, Keanu Reeves performed
the stunt riding in this scene,
skills he originally acquired while shooting the
2013 action and fantasy film "47 Ronin." In order
to keep Reeves safe while filming the scene,
the crew set-up a custom wire-harness to act as
a safety net in case he fell, or the horse took
off unexpectedly. Even with the safety harness,
Reeves had some close calls, which required him
to quickly pull his feet out of the stirrups and,
quote, “make [himself] small" so as to not to hit
anything. It sounds like Reeves' job, sometimes,
is almost as dangerous as that of John Wick.
In an ironic twist, the Russian
thug who orchestrated breaking
into John's house was the son of
Russian crime boss Viggo Tarasov.
As we learn in the original film, Wick and
Tarasov were former associates when he was
still an assassin, before Wick quit his life of
crime and killing to settle down and marry Helen.
So, after Viggo learns what his son has
done, he warns Iosef about Wick's, quote,
"focus, commitment, and sheer will,"
comparing him to the Russian Boogeyman.
“They call him Baba Yaga.”
To give his heedless son an
idea of how dangerous Wick is,
Viggo tells Iosef about how he once killed three
men in a bar using only a pencil. This story is
later repeated by Viggo's brother in "Chapter
2," but Stahelski wasn't content to just let
his audience hear about this mind-boggling
feat. Later in "Chapter 2," Wick would bring
the legend to life by re-creating it
while escaping assassins in New York.
Cornered by two men in a small café area, and
bleeding badly, the scene has Wick managing to
deflect one assassin's gunshot while grabbing
for a pencil lying by a server's notepad.
Then, he stabs one assailant in the
chest with the writing implement.
He uses a second pencil to vanquish the
other assassin and finish off the first.
The stabs are in places quite undelightful to
watch, eliciting squeamish squeals from many
a-viewer. It can't help but make you look at
office supplies in a whole new, twisted light.
In "Parabellum," John Wick adds to the list of
random inanimate objects he uses to kill people,
when he executes a fellow assassin using only
a book in the New York Public Library. You
would think a library would provide a safe
haven to read, but even there Wick can find
no peace. Boban Marjanovic of the Dallas
Mavericks plays his towering opponent,
Ernest. He corners Wick down one of the abandoned
aisles and uses his long limbs to his advantage.
To make matters worse, Marjanovic's character
has a knife and manages to strike true,
stabbing Wick in the shoulder after a few
deflected shots. Then, he grabs Wick and
kicks him down the aisles while loudly and
ironically whispering for him to be quiet.
“Shhh.”
The tides turn for Wick when he
manages to grab a particularly
thick tome and hit Ernest squarely in
the crotch, throat, and face with it.
Wick follows with a crushing death blow by placing
the book on a tabletop, smashing Ernest's face
into the spine. He bends his neck and jaw back in
horrific angles accompanied by a sickening crack.
Perhaps one of the wildest sequences in the
"John Wick" films takes place in "Parabellum."
While on the run from ninjas, Wick makes a stop
inside an antique weapons store to arm himself
Old West style. His foes follow him inside
and they all begin volleying knives at one
another like Nerf darts, shattering countless
glass display cases and mirrors in the process.
One of the ninjas gets stabbed in the
back by two knives thrown by his comrade,
before being stabbed in the groin and
a few other areas of the body by Wick.
Much more stabbing follows, culminating with
one of the last surviving ninjas getting
slowly shanked in the eye, which is super
uncomfortable to watch. To top it all off,
Wick finishes off the last ninja by throwing a
tomahawk into his skull from across the room.
It may look like chaos, but this sequence was
intricately planned, and took a massive amount
of effort to complete. Stahelski told Polygon the
inspiration for this scene came from "The Good,
The Bad and The Ugly," when the big bad Tuco went
into a gun shop after-hours for supplies. After
starting with that spark of inspiration, Stahelski
expanded the scene to include an epic knife fight,
akin to what he eloquently described as a,
quote, "snowball fight" — only far deadlier.
Many scenes in the "John Wick" films use a
combination of CGI and practical effects to
create images that would otherwise be
impossible or incredibly dangerous to
perform without digital aid. One such
example is an epic motorcycle chase
scene in "Parabellum," when some of Zero's
ninjas are chasing Wick through Brooklyn.
The scene gets even spicier when the ninjas pull
out katanas and attempt to slice and dice Wick
while they're all riding around on two wheels.
Wick manages to turn their sword against them,
skewering ninjas like shish kabobs,
who then crash into each other in an
explosive domino effect. Despite
the hyper-realism of this scene,
the riders hitting the pavement were
all edited into the scene with CGI,
layered into shots with real actors astride
motorcycle sled-rigs mounted in front of green
screens. The cringe-inducing scenes go to show how
great of a job the visual effects team performed.
Burning to death sounds like one of the most
painful ways to face your final moments.
Even so, those are the consequences for being
complicit in the killing of John Wick's dog
and theft of his car. This fiery moment of
vengeance takes place in the original film
when Wick finally locates Iosef Tarasov, thanks
to his dad Viggo sharing the information with
the determined assassin. It seems there's no
honor among thieves, even when they're family.
Wick tracks Iosef and his thugs
to a safehouse in Brooklyn,
which suddenly becomes no longer safe, and
the thugs flee for their cars in hopes of
a quick escape. However, Wick remotely
blows up their cars before they can flee,
which explode in spectacular fashion. When did
he have time to plant bombs on multiple cars?
Who cares! They go "boom" while Keanu Reeves
walks in slow-motion, and that's what matters.
While trying to make one final desperate
escape, Wick shoots Iosef in the stomach,
before shooting him in the head while he's in
the process of protesting that it was just a dog.
Though, he actually got off easy compared to
the guys who caught fire from the car
bombs. And a dog is never just a dog.
John may not be able to bring his puppy
Daisy back, but at least he's able to reunite
with his car. "Chapter 2" opens with Wick
infiltrating the chop shop of Abram Tarasov,
uncle and brother to the late Iosef and Viggo,
respectively. With Wick's '69 Mustang in his shop,
he fears the "Boogeyman" will come for his
car, and leave a path of collateral damage
in his wake. Abram fills an accomplice in on
the gritty details of Wick's capabilities and
their serious predicament. While Tarasov is
telling his story, Wick is right outside,
working his way into the shop by quietly
taking out Abram's guys one at a time.
One of those guys is on a smoke break when Wick
sneaks up behind him, and as Tarasov's voiceover
plays on, describing Wick's focus, commitment,
and sheer will, Wick shoves the cigarette down
the man's throat from the rear, then punches him
in the gut and while covering his mouth, forces
the smoldering cigarette down the man's throat.
One can only imagine how brutally that would
hurt. After decades of folks complaining that
Hollywood glamorizes smoking, here's one scene
that would seem to drive home another, albeit
rare, danger associated with nicotine addiction.
Wick continues his quest to get his car
back with his next most brutal kill,
which follows shortly after choking
Abram's thug with his own cigarette.
The vengeful assassin sneaks up behind the next
baddie he crosses paths with at the chop shop,
only this bad guy has made the
wise decision not to smoke.
So Wick does what he does best, and improvises
by taking him down and choking him with a wire.
It seems like a very slow, painful way to die,
especially compared to how quickly a lot of the
other deaths occur in the film via more "humane"
manners, such as point-blank gunshots. This may
seem like a hard death to swallow, but many
follow in John Wick's bloody footsteps. At
least he gets his car back, even if he does
immediately trash it while making his getaway.
It just goes to show with the right level of
focus, commitment, and sheer will, anything is
possible — even killing hundreds of people in
endlessly creative and savage ways. Stahelski
told the Los Angeles Times in 2019 that he and
his stunt team got bored easily with repetition,
so it will be interesting to see how they keep all
the killing feeling novel in the upcoming films.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.